in this episode of the secret manager
video series
we'll talk about the principle of least
privilege
and how you can limit who can access
your secrets
do you want to limit access to your
secrets stay tuned to find out how
[Music]
the principle of least privilege says
that an entity
must only be able to access the
information
or resources necessary to perform its
function
in the context of secret manager this
means humans
and machines should only have access to
the secrets that are required to perform
their function
for example a security engineer may have
full control to create and manage
secrets
but an application developer may only
have permission to access
a single secret but how do we accomplish
this to tell us more about how to adopt
the principle of least privilege with
secret manager
i think we need to bring in an expert
hey nick thanks for joining us today
thanks seth
thank you so much for having me so
nick is a software engineer at google
who works on secret manager
nick earlier i was telling our viewers
about
the principle of least privilege could
you
tell us a little bit more about how
secret manager helps users adopt this
principle
sure seth so in google cloud most
controls are implemented using cloud
identity and access management or i
am iam provides very granular
permissions that are combined into roles
secret manager currently offers five
granular cloud iam roles
first is the secret manager admin im
role
which grants full access to administer
secret manager resources
including creating and deleting secrets
then the secret manager viewer i am role
grants permission to view the secret
metadata on secret manager resources
but it does not include the ability to
access secret payloads
this is useful for auditing secrets
without actually
seeing the payloads inside
then the secret manager secret accessor
im role
grants the ability to access secret
payloads but does not grant any
administrative permissions
this is useful for humans and
applications that need to access a
secret but don't need permissions to
manage those secrets
the secret manager version manager iam
role
permission grants permissions uh to
manage versions of existing secrets but
it does not include
the ability to access secret payloads or
view or
update the metadata on any secrets
themselves
finally the secret manager version adder
i
am role grants permissions to add new
versions to existing secrets but it does
not include the ability to access
secret payloads or manage any versions
or secrets
this is useful for applications that
might need to perform simple rotations
okay so it sounds like secret manager
has this
really nice separation of concerns
between
managing secrets auditing secrets
rotating secrets and accessing secrets
so this will definitely help me adopt
that principle of least privilege
but wouldn't granting someone secret
manager's secret
access or permissions give them access
to
all of the secrets in my project yeah so
that really depends on where you grant
that i
am permission secret managers i am roles
can be applied
globally on a whole project or
individually
on just a single secret if you grant an
entity
like a user the secret manager secret
accessor role
on the project then that entity can
access all the secrets in the project
but if you grant the secret manager
secret accessor role to just an entity
on a single secret
then that entity will only be able to
access that one secret
okay so it sounds like if i really want
to follow that principle of least
privilege
i should apply iam roles at the most
granular level
that's right since cloud iam's default
policy is to deny
applying roles at the most granular
level is what really helps you achieve
that principle of these privilege
okay awesome but google cloud has these
built-in roles like
project editor and project owner how do
those built-in roles map to these secret
manager permissions
and that's a really good question um so
project owners are kind of like super
users
so they have full permissions to access
and manage secrets
even if we remove this permission they
could just grant it to themselves
because
uh they're also full i am policy
administrators
okay that makes sense we could take it
away but they could just
you know add it back themselves yeah
well however perhaps unlike other dcp
services
the ability to access secrets and the
ability to change i am permissions on
secrets
is not actually granted to the project
editor role
and that includes the default compute
engine service account
this means that only project owners and
entities who are explicitly granted
permissions
can access secrets in your project
awesome thank you so much nick this
really makes it clearer
how secret manager can help adopt the
principle of least privilege
okay let's take a look at how to
practice the principle of least
privilege
with google secret manager i created a
secret that contains my twilio api key
and i need to grant my cloud function
permissions to access that secret
now i could go to the cloud iam settings
and grant my cloud function service
account the secret manager
accessor permissions but as we learned
from nick
that isn't a best practice because that
would allow
my cloud function to access all of the
secrets in the project
instead we want to follow the principle
of least privilege
and grant access only to the secrets
that my cloud function needs
to do this i'll head over to the secret
manager console
select my secret expand the info panel
click add member and grant my cloud
function service account permissions to
access the secret
here i apply the iam policy at the
secret level
meaning my cloud function won't have
access to the other secrets in my
project
i could also grant this permission using
the gcloud command line tool
or from the api using any of the secret
manager sdks
for net go java node
php python and ruby
google secret manager makes it easy to
adopt and practice the principle of
least privilege
that's all for this episode in the next
episode
we'll talk about audit logging and
forensics with secret manager
be sure to like subscribe and click the
bell to get notifications about new
episodes for even more tips and tricks
with google secret manager
click subscribe to google cloud platform
[Music]
you